at some point you have to decide whose
life you're living are you living your
version of your life are you living your
parents version of your life or your
friend's version of your life or your
community's version of your life or
society's version of your life so
everybody has a goal for you everybody
has an idea of what you should do with
your life everybody's an opinion on how
you should be who you should marry what
job you should take on how many kids you
should have what profession to get into
what country to live in everybody's got
an opinion on what you should do with
your life and when you are not sending
on a rock solid foundation what ends up
happening is you get pulled in a million
different directions like there is no
way that you're going to make everybody
happy there's no way because there's
different competing opinions and so if
you're trying to make this group happy
and then that group happy and then this
group happened that group happy you end
up making nobody happy and worst of all
you're not happy
biggest problem is all of all is that
you're not happy need motivation watch
the top 10 with believe Nation hey Tevin
Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I was
making 300 bucks a month I quit on my
business partner and the thing that
saved me was studying the stories of
super successful entrepreneurs so I hope
that this story today helps give you the
motivation you need because I still
needed to myself so today let's learn
from me and my team's take on my top 10
rules of success enjoy
I had um somebody message me on
Instagram the other day
saying that
they want to chase down their
aspirational dreams be an entrepreneur
but their parents won't let them
okay
well at some point you have to decide
when are you living your life
and when are you living your parents
version of your life
and what that requires is you
getting off the payroll
right
if you want to live your life but you're
living under their roof that's a problem
right
when do you stand up for yourself and
maybe if you're 13 years old that's
that's too young maybe you can't do it
maybe that's not possible Right but is
it at 16 is it at 18 is it a 20 is it at
24 is that 32 is it at 46 like it's
people in their 50s still living the
life that their parents want for them
instead of a lot that they want for them
or again their Community their partner
or the people around them Society you're
not living your version of your life
and so how do we fix it how do you gain
the courage how do you gain the strength
how do you get the momentum maybe a
couple strategies that I hope will help
number one is to figure out you're who
what you're saying the most important
core value I wrote a book called your
one word and another one called built to
serve in the first exercise that I guide
people through is to figure out what is
your single most important core value
what do you stand for as a human you
know and you can read the books to dive
in deeper but if you just
thought about it he spent two seconds
and thought about it close your eyes and
ask yourself what is my single most
important core value as a human
what is it
and then from there
you gain
a new sense of strength and courage
because mine is belief right so if you
look at mine believe well I need to then
do things that are in accordance with
belief whenever I'm not happy whenever
I'm not
a bold whenever I'm feeling down is
because there's a lack of belief
somewhere in my life
because I want to be doing something but
I'm not I don't believe in myself or I
don't believe in the thing that I'm
doing
it it adds a level of clarity that
didn't have before
so what's yours what's your single most
important core value you know what do
you stand for as a human and don't worry
about being perfect but if you're not
happy right now if your most important
core value is freedom and you are
feeling trapped
under somebody else's rules you're not
gonna be happy you know why because your
most core value is freedom
right it says to make sense
so identify what your what that core
value is because it'll help you make
better decisions it gives you the rock
to stand on instead of standing on
quicksand if you're being pulled in a
million different directions by other
people on their agenda for your time
it's because you do not have that rock
you know something is wrong you know
you're sinking but you don't know why
and you don't know how to stand strong
this is it you're seeing the most
important core value figure out your who
that's step number one
step number two is once you figure out
your who
we need to start to limit access or cut
out the things that make us feel against
that so if my who is believe then
anything that makes me feel a lack of
belief I want to stop spending time with
I want to unsubscribe from the channels
that make me feel less than I want to
stop spending time with friends who pull
me down I want to
dedicate myself to
not being around the negativity
you know think about the last time you
scroll through Instagram or you're
scrolling through YouTube how many of
the videos and pieces of content that
you watch make you feel better about
yourself right like did it make you feel
better about yourself or Worse about
yourself
that's an important question thank you
to make you feel better about yourself
or Worse about yourself
and if it's worse about yourself if you
just found yourself scrolling for 40
minutes through Instagram and now you
feel like a loser it's not Instagram's
problem
it's not the platform's fault it's the
people that you're following
stop following the people who make you
feel worse about yourself how do you
know well you have an audit right now
that you know you're seeing the most
important core value you have a gauge so
for me does this person that I'm
subscribed to are following make me feel
more or less believe cool that becomes
an easy decision what to do next right
then you go to the people in your life
your friends your family through these
people make me feel more or less believe
for me right insert your word for you
cool less stop spending time with them
maybe maybe completely cut out access or
if it's you know your parents or
somebody really close to you then put up
walls over the things that you will talk
about
limit access you may not go to the
extreme of completely cutting the person
out of your life but at least limiting
access so that
that you don't wake up every day and
feel
terrible
right I think that stuff matters so step
number one is we're gonna figure out our
most important core value what's your
hoop right step number two is then we're
gonna restrict access or cut off the
people the things that we're feeding
into our mind that make us feel worse
about ourselves and then three is we
need to inject new great things into our
lives we need to inject new positive
amazing people into our lives right
people who make you feel your core value
belief for me right so I wanna I make my
videos still for myself
the videos on my Channel I want to watch
for myself and thankfully you guys like
it enough that I can turn it into a
business bring on an amazing team and
help go off and Inspire even more people
but it's a conscious choice
you know most of us wake up like an
accident and fall into our day and it's
time to make a conscious choice to shift
that to say no instead what I'm going to
do is I'm going to be really intentional
with who I'm spending my time with what
I'm feeding into my mind
because that'll make a giant difference
in how you show up if you're constantly
around negativity destruction
pessimism it's not that you can't show
up and be great it's just you're making
things a thousand times harder for
yourself versus and you know you've felt
that when you're around the people or
you're in the environment where you feel
bold and Powerful Unstoppable and you
can do anything guess what you go off
and you start doing amazing things that
you never thought you were capable of
and so that's the key difference
you have to protect your dream
you have to realize that everybody has
that
dream for you and it's not really for
you it's mostly for them
right it's like they gave up on their
dreams they never chase down their goals
and so now they're putting all their
hopes on you they want you to go live
the life that they never had
but that's not a fair
burden to carry because you don't want
their life you don't want the same
things that they want that's not what
you want to do
and so if you can go through that
process
and recognize that yes you have Michael
Jordan a level genius at something right
you have Michael Jordan level genius as
something
you can be great
and it's probably not doing the thing
that your parents wanted you to do or
your family your community what you grew
up learning in school it's probably
something completely different
and when you can figure out your most
important core value when you can
completely eliminate or cut off access
to the people the things that bring you
down and we can inject the positivity
into your life on a daily basis on a
consistent basis it'll change everything
everything
time to get to work rule number two is
challenge your values figuring out your
core values I think is one of the most
important exercises that you can do as a
human being
how do you know how to live your life
how do you wake up every day and do
what you want to do how do you have any
Clarity on what to do next when you
don't know what you stand for you don't
know your most important core value it's
the reason why I wrote your one word
I don't know how many years ago the
concept is you have one most important
core value what is it figure it out when
you understand what it is it'll shine a
giant Spotlight on your life to realize
oh this is why I'm not happy like if you
are ever not happy
frustrated stressed out
it's because there's too many things
that are going on in your life that are
out of
congruence with your single most
important core value
so if you look at mine it's belief right
I believe is my single most important
provide Okay cool so I'm happy when I'm
doing things that make me feel believe
and it's something that you you have for
yourself but it's also something that
then you give to other people so you're
on a mission the idea becomes I want to
spread belief for myself and I also want
to help other people believe in
themselves more whatever you come up
with is a core value is for you is what
you still need the most right now I
still need belief right now
but it's also something that we want to
give to other people whether it's the
world if you're watching this video is
probably world big mission but uh it
could just be the closest people to you
you know if you're saying the most
important core value is family then you
want to bring more family to your family
every single most important core value
is belonging then you want to give
belonging to everybody to yourself you
still need to feel more belong yourself
and you want to give that to the world
or your closest friends and family
but that's that's the game you have to
figure out your single most important
core value
if you feel like you're being pulled in
a thousand directions that's why you
don't know what you stand for if you
feel uneasy about something or unsure
about the decision that's also why you
don't know what you're staying for and
when you figure that out it gives you
the courage to take the action required
when you understand what your single
most important core value is it allows
you
to step into your career yourself to
step into your bold self it gives you
the permission to move forward where old
you wouldn't have done it you know if
you had those moments where you really
want to do something
you're inspired you've got a great idea
as if you want to serve you want to help
you think this could be amazing and then
you stop yourself you know you stop
yourself oh I who am I I can't do that
I'm not I'm not well known enough I
don't have the money I didn't go to
school for this I don't have the
connections the parents right we stop
ourselves
we were planning to plan and getting
ready to get ready but we never actually
do the thing well figuring out your core
value
allows you to have the courage and
strength to step into who you want to be
how can my one word be believed if I'm
not willing to do the things to believe
in myself even something like this
feeling on the street this used to
terrify me I remember the first video
that I made when I was walking down the
street
uh it's probably about a decade ago my
agent challenged me to do it and I was
terrified I was terrified the people
might judge me I was terrified that uh
just looking foolish and looking bad I
don't know it was just terrified filming
in public and I remember I was filming
and I made sure I walked down just this
really quiet street where nobody would
see me and made sure I looked around and
nobody was there and I started filming
and then there was a male woman who came
by she was delivering mail I didn't see
her before I started filming and so
as she walked by I I thought I was like
this
put the camera down you know it's like
I'm not doing anything nope and then
when she left she's like okay back to
filming and uh
you know now now I mean how many
thousands of videos later I'm much more
able to get out in front of the camera
and create but what's the thing that
helps me push what's the help what's the
thing that gives me the confidence and
courage to do that thing that was
incredibly scary at the time well
believe hey my one word is belief my
most important core value is believe so
I need to I need to step into it it's a
it's a constant reminder
it always forces you to be not the
version that somebody else wants for you
but the version that you want for you
believe was was is inside me it's not
that it was just given to me by somebody
you don't have to have Believers your
core value either you can figure what
yours is
but if ever you're stuck with a big
decision
and you're not sure what to do and you
actually know what your most important
core value is then guess what happens
forces you to go and take some action
because otherwise you're operating
against yourself and you don't need
somebody yelling at you or telling you
what you should do you know what you
should do because you have the awareness
around your core value when I wrote your
one word it was it was designed for
entrepreneurs
because it's about how to find your core
value but then how to build into a
business and
I was surprised that a lot of the people
who liked the book were not just the
entrepreneurs but the the spouses and
the family members of the entrepreneurs
who read the book to say okay they don't
want to start a business but they need
this first part kids in school are
reading the book and send me pictures
and tweets as they go through the
curriculum to figure out what their most
important core value is like can you
imagine being in grade six
seven eight ten
and knowing what your most important
core value is and using that as a lens
to which you can make decisions for the
rest of your life
how beautiful is that
I wish I had that I mean that's why
that's why we do what we do right that's
why that's why authors write books
that's why entrepreneurs start
businesses is we want to solve the
problems that we had for ourselves when
we want to make the path a little bit
easier for other people right that's why
we do what we do
so how do you find your core value well
you can you can pick up your one word
you can pick up built to serve but as a
starting point
think about who your favorite teacher
was growing up and why
think about your favorite teacher of all
time mine was mine was Madame Farr who
was my teacher Mentor in my last year of
high school but who was yours who's your
favorite teacher growing up and why and
specifically on the why wasn't because
they taught you a certain subject I
didn't like Madame Farr because she
taught me French right I don't even use
French day to day at all even living in
Canada we don't use French
but uh but she got me to believe in
myself
so there's one what's your favorite
movie of all time and why mine is
Seabiscuit I love sea biscuits about
this horse it's way too small to win not
supposed to win a jockey that's way too
big to win and not supposed to win an
owner that has no money and is not
supposed to win it's like all the stuff
that's not supposed to happen and yet
they all find each other and somehow A
Miracle of Miracles they figured out and
they win a whole bunch of races it's
based off a true story it's it's a
belief story at least for me when I
think about that movie why do I love it
well it's about belief
think about your parents
you know maybe you love your parents
maybe you hate your parents uh what do
you what was the biggest lesson you
learned from them like what did you love
the most even if you didn't like your
parents or didn't think they were there
for you or you know whatever what what
did you love about them or if there's
nothing redeemable that you can find
then what did you wish that they gave
you what do you want to give to your
kids right current kids or future kids
if you had to give them one lesson what
would that be again mine is believe my
parents always taught me hey you're
having extremely Carmichael you can do
anything you believe that you can so
believe is a Common Thread through all
these things if you think about oh this
why is this why does this matter if you
think about all the things that made you
come alive all the thing all the best
moments in your life all the positivity
all the happiness all the the best
moments in your life
there's a Common Thread between them you
know so for me is Bully man I'm far Sea
Biscuit my parents the Common Thread is
believe
when you figure what that threat is for
you what it allows you to do is now
design a life going forward with more
intention
so now instead of it happening by
accident you know I just happen to find
that I'm far I just happened to find Sea
Biscuit it wasn't intentional most of us
are not doing that with any level of
intentionality it's just that
random things happen and every now and
then one of those random things are good
right but now it allows you to design a
life with more intentionality to say
this is what I stand for
this is who I am at the core
these are the things that make me happy
I want to chase down the feeling of X
believe for me right I want to chase
down that feeling I believe more I want
to be around the people who help make me
believe I want to create content and the
business that inspires people to believe
I want to hire teammates
people on my in my business we got 40
people now I wanna I wanna bring on
people who believe in the mission
believe in spreading believe believe in
each other right it's like it just gives
so much more clarity
and intentionality for the rest of your
life
and so I think it's one of the most
important exercises that you can ever do
just as a human I don't know why we
don't teach this stuff in school you
should
because how do you operate your life
without knowing what you're saying for
how do you operate without knowing who
you are
that seems crazy
and it's not that difficult and you
don't have to go meditate on the
mountain for five years to figure it out
you don't have to hire a ten thousand
dollar coach to figure it out
just ask yourself those questions
who's your favorite teacher growing up
and why
what's your favorite movie of all time
and why what did you love about your
parents or what's the gift that you want
to give your kids the most important
core value coming through those things
that'll give you a much better path and
direction
and Clarity and strength and courage
for the rest of your life rule number
three is be impact driven I'm super
introverted and shy and this it took me
that's why it took me so long to get
going on YouTube because I I don't uh I
don't like the camera like I don't come
alive on the camera
um and the biggest fight I would get
into of an agent in New York named Steve
who he helped uh Grant Cardone blow up
and now Robin blow up and a bunch of
thought leaders and uh he's like Evan
you need to be famous like I don't want
to be famous dude and that was our
biggest fight for years yeah and it
wasn't until he either said it in a
certain way or maybe I just finally
wasn't you know being a dummy and like
could receive it uh where he said well
the more people know you the more people
will get the message yeah and for me
it's always message and impact driven
first more than my face being somewhere
um and so once I realized that like oh
okay so the more people know me the more
people will hear my message which sounds
basic you know but I you know for the
first five years I didn't understand
that yeah and so I'm I'm great at like
two things and apart from that I know
nothing about everything else
um and so luckily I guess in some of our
circles I have a knowledge on something
that people care about yeah
um when I when I went to that group you
know I was like well what am I gonna I
teach believe you know it's what I'm
what I'm in your book it's the whole
mission that I'm on and like I'm gonna
I'm gonna teach Anthony trucks to
believe in himself more or like Brendan
Bashar to believe himself like why am I
here yeah yeah but I realize yeah like
the YouTube side into to the point of
you know the Candor which you you said
graciously in the beginning
it's what Achievers appreciate you know
I think for people at the very beginning
of their Journey most people they need
just the encouragement and the the pat
on the back and the high five and like
you can do this and get going and create
and just the fact that they made a video
or they they called that person like
that's a huge win the fact that they
took any kind of action and so most of
what I do is is just cheerleading and
encouragement because that's what
they're missing is just momentum yeah
for the Achievers though it's like you
don't you don't need you don't need me
to say hey trucks like
you posted a video great job man no it's
like okay that's cool but you're like
okay where does it suck how do I improve
it and you were asking some questions
too it's okay like be honest tell me
like rip it apart yeah shred it tell me
everywhere it sucks
um and so the Achievers want more of the
push because they're they don't need the
pat on the back like how do I get better
yeah rule number four is find your
people you know there's a great quote um
find people or find someone in your life
not to grow old with but to stay young
with
you know and and that we can apply we
typically think about that as our
significant others but but those could
just be the people that are in your life
the people like you stay young by
watching Eric
you know like you get this you're still
on a parallel path like Eric and I are
on this parallel path right now with all
you guys and maybe I never see Eric
again in my life or maybe we we start a
multi-billion dollar Venture Capital
fund together and change the world like
who knows right like you never know how
long I can feel a little path you'll be
on with somebody right
um but
like be on the path of the people who
make you feel the way that you want to
feel that you can stay young with that
you can you can express yourself that
they're pushing you in a loving way not
another you need to go off and do this
Eric because you suck right like
everybody has an opinion on what we
should do with our lives and there's
some very rare people that we come
across them I like the expression I
collect good people that's what I like
to talk about collect good people when
you see someone that you like and it
makes you feel better about yourself
when you're around them find a way to
spend more time with them because they
will make a really really big difference
in your life and if you're listening to
this show you are probably the one
pouring into other people you know like
we're we're pouring into other people
you're the most optimistic person you
know you're the happiest person you know
you're the most ambitious person that
you know you're the most service-minded
person you know and that's awesome keep
pointing to others but who's pointing to
you
who's encouraging you who's sharing in a
loving way again like hey you could be
doing you could be doing so much more
like why don't we do this together and
when you find those people like collect
them hold on to them be around them more
because it'll make a huge huge
difference in your life also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is analyze your
audience YouTube has the best data
platform of all of all those social
media networks and um I love the day and
I can geek out on it all day long and
dive into it it's overwhelming for a lot
of people the only thing you have to
care about is this the audience
retention curve like write that down if
you don't know what I'm talking about
and you think you might at some day want
to start a YouTube channel come back to
that write it down it is your golden
ticket the audience retention curve what
that does is show you second by second
where people are either falling off your
video or sticking around second by
second so if your intros are really bad
it'll show you you lost half your
audience in the first 20 seconds cool
like let's not do that again and it'll
show you these little flat moments and a
flat moment means you never lost anybody
like whatever you did in that moment was
really good right you held their
attention that whole time think of it
like if you ever watch those elections
and uh the election debates and there's
like the red and the blue in America
right and you you like which who are you
liking more and they've got these people
in the audience who are kind of neutral
people or supposedly neutral and they're
like they're as the person's talking you
see the Blue Line go up or the red line
go up it's kind of like that on your
videos and it's completely free you
don't have to pay for any service or
anything else it's built into YouTube
natively in their analytics so when it's
a flat line when it's a downline then
okay that sucks we need to fix that
don't do that again but a flat moment is
good flat moment is good that means
you've kept their attention so if you
have a flat moment that's 40 seconds
long cool what happened there let's turn
that into a tweet let's turn it into an
Instagram reel let's turn them into
something else and then you have these
rare moments these special moments where
it goes up
well how's it go up like we lost people
we understand why it goes down but how
do we gain people in the middle of the
video it doesn't make sense right
because most people drop off like in the
first few seconds or whatever minutes is
the big fall off but then you it doesn't
just go down there's these spikes yeah
so why does it Spike like how does that
make sense if new people join the video
halfway through right usually not
usually what the case is is the people
who are currently watching rewound that
video to watch that part again it's like
what did Rory just say what was that
thing again and they rewinded to watch
that part again that's your goal and
that may be 20 minutes inside of your
video but that's what we cut and one we
want to make more content like that like
that can educate you to make better
content but then that also that's what
we cut so the flat moments or the spikes
that's what we cut to take to our other
social media accounts because we know
that that's popping and a lot of people
who are making content whether they're
doing it themselves or they have Team
there's a lot of subjective decisions
that go into like well I like that part
and I like this moment and I think we
should do here and there's a lot of
wasted time to be honest and going back
and reviewing and watching the footage
again and then relying on one person's
subjective opinion to make the call on
what goes through the platforms to make
your your diamond
um the data will show you it's a lot
easier just look at where we help people
on the video and let's take that to our
other platforms rule number six is
choose your platform I'm a visual
learner I like to be able to see stuff
so I don't listen to any podcasts I'm on
a bunch of podcasts but Audio Only is
the is the hardest way for me to learn
this is a podcast but the fact that I
can see you helps because otherwise I'd
be like I'd be closing my eyes I'd be
covering my ears because it's really
it's just the hardest way for me to
learn Audio Only
when I started in 2009 on YouTube uh it
was the only video platform so it wasn't
that I knew it was going to be huge like
nobody had a million subscribers being a
YouTuber wasn't even a thing I was
making six minute videos and people were
telling me that it was way too long and
I didn't understand how the internet
worked and all of this stuff yeah uh so
I mean it's come a long way since 2009
but it was just the only visual place at
the time and I I wanted to I wanted to
share so
most of the stuff was either my own what
I had learned or what I had learned from
Steve Jobs or Oprah Winfrey or Kanye
West or whoever and sharing their
lessons with the world because that's
what really saved my company and I
thought like you know 50 people watched
the video maybe that changes somebody's
life it was never designed like now
there's a whole there's a whole business
model around it right like you could
create entire Mega corporations around
it and people are going to YouTube to
learn you know it's the education
platform now
so it was very different when I got
started it was just I want to tell
stories I want to help people and and I
like video because it's a visual
platform if you're getting started now
and you're trying to figure out where
should I be
the strength of YouTube is that it's the
only long form
video platform around right so if you're
gonna do if you do a video podcast we're
gonna host it you're not going to post a
hour it's so it's YouTube and and
YouTube is now the educational place to
people default to so if somebody's
trying to figure out how to make a big
shift in their life where are they gonna
go are they going to the library you
know are they going to talk to their mom
like they're going to YouTube and
there's like how do I make a shift and
there's Anthony trucks it's like I've
never heard of this guy but he's got
awesome message right and then that's
how you start to bring on new people and
build your movement up all of the other
platforms are still great
but they'd lean in more on the
inspirational side so Instagram Tick
Tock it's great you know you can give
you have a minute to say something
really fantastic and it's just hoping to
plant the seed with people but you're
not really making a shift in a minute
long video for people and so where short
form goes there's lots of different
options there's no there's no
bunch of people tried to come make the
YouTube killer there's no YouTube killer
out yet but who knows in 10 years we're
going to be doing this in VR I'm going
to be holograming into your room you
know look at the technology will change
but right now if you are an expert if
you're a thought leader and that's all I
focus on right I'm not the YouTube guy
for like slime channels or makeup
tutorials or whatever it's like
education thought leadership
entrepreneurship person development
that's where I live
um YouTube needs to be your number one
home rule number seven is share your
glory a lot of people don't believe that
I'm an introvert and that I'm shy
because of the work that I do and it's
uh I struggled a lot with it Eric like
if you look at the growth of my YouTube
channel at the beginning it was so slow
uh mostly because I was I thought hey if
you're going to talk about yourself you
have to have a huge ego and you have to
be a a blabbermouth and just it wasn't
me it's not how I wanted to win and then
I realized well I I still want to serve
like how do I I still want to help how
do I help and once I could marry oh when
I if I share my story that actually can
serve people then it got me more and
more comfortable and I would never have
said yes to this like what what does he
want to talk to me it's crazy no I'm not
coming on Eric's show just because I
would be nothing nothing about you more
I'm just too afraid and too nervous and
too shy like I don't want to talk to
people
um
I do a lot of my best creative work you
know when I'm by myself I actually have
no need to as long as I have my wife I'm
pretty good
you know like I don't really have a huge
connection need but I want to serve I
don't want to feel like what I'm doing
matters and is important so I can get
really excited about a few things right
like if we're talking about impact and
Entrepreneurship or if you want to dive
into salsa dancing or League of Legends
I can get pretty excited but anything
else you know I I no interest small talk
you know how about how about that local
hockey team or weather like I don't it
just is not interesting to me and I
think that's one of the things with with
introverts is we we want to have
meaningful conversations we're actually
okay to have conversations but we're
better in small groups or one-on-ones
and we want to have meaningful
conversations and we hate the small talk
and what do you do and
um just the the yeah just the small talk
is just not fun
um I remember I was on a flight I was
going from
Toronto to Puerto Rico speaking at
Brendan burchard's event in Puerto Rico
for his high-end Mastermind group and um
there was a guy next to me and uh he was
trying to start up all these
conversations they're like just I I
don't I just don't I don't I don't I
don't enjoy it
laughs
but I remembered everything about him I
remember you know the backpack that he
had and then he wanted a coffee once we
got into the air and he wanted a black
and you know I remembered all the all
the things about him but I just I don't
like the small talk conversation
um and then we got there and I took the
cab and got to the hotel and then in
behind me walks the same guy he was
going to the same event in Puerto Rico
and uh as soon as I saw him there he's
like oh dude you're an entrepreneur like
what do you do
as soon as I got into a you know service
and Entrepreneurship then instantly
became friends
um but just small talk is not as and
maybe that's the limitation to me or
something I need to work on
um but
the most important part of that was
realizing hey I need to get out there
because I want to serve and I want to
help in me not sharing my stories
actually selfish like we've all been
through something and there are other
people who are struggling right now with
the thing that you used to struggle with
if you think back to who you were 10
years ago and how much you were
struggling and just a difference in
mindsets and belief systems compared to
who you are now there's a lot of people
who are still stuck at who you were 10
years ago and they need help and they
don't know who to go to and they can't
connect to some of the big names out
there but they can connect to you
because you know exactly what they've
been through and you can you can help
that person and just sharing your story
is valuable and in you being silent it
perpetuates a silence for others and in
you sharing it and expressing yourself
to you know to your word uh it
encourages other people to express
themselves too it gives them permission
to express themselves too they may not
look to me and say the is possible for
them but they can look at you Eric and
say well Eric can do it he's like me he
went through the same things as I did if
he can do it then maybe I can too and
you sharing your story and expressing
yourself gives them permission to take
the step and start on their Journey as
well which is the greatest thing of all
time so even though
you know we're introverts you still want
to help still want to serve still want
to feel like what we do matters every
day rule number eight is Project
realistic possibilities the fastest way
to figure out what to do next is to
model success model success whenever you
don't know what to do model success
what that does is
when you can find somebody who's done
the thing that you want to do right like
they think about what are your goals
what do you want to accomplish what do
you want to what do you want to do in
life right in life and business what do
you want to do what do you want to
accomplish where do you want to go find
people who've done it
and the key the key thing is
we're doing right now
[Music]
and said what we want to do is look at
what do they do when they started
how do they go from zero to one how do
they get their thing off the ground
because it it does it does two key
things it gives you hope that it's
possible whenever you look at your
Heroes mentors people who've done
amazing things
we often feel when we look at our goals
that it's not possible because that
happened to you you look at your goals
your big goals not not your little ones
but the big goals like that's not
possible I can't do that sometimes you
feel like you can and it's inspiring
like yes I can't wait to do that and
other times it feels like the big goal
is too big and you're never gonna be
able to do that right is that does that
sound familiar so then when you're able
to see people who have done it it gives
you the hope the motivation the
inspiration that you can do it too and
if you look at their store you'll see
that they probably started with less
than what you already have right now
chances are Your Heroes they started
with less than what you already have
right now
and if they could do it why can't you
because of the story that you're telling
yourself and so being around those
stories being around those people even
if it's from from books and videos and
podcasts right being around that makes
you realize holy cow this is possible
the second thing it does is it gives you
strategies it's like well what did they
do not just the motivation to act but
what specifically to do how did they do
it how did they get started
this is what saved my business Bill
Gates I like to say save my business I
haven't met Bill Gates yet but he saved
my business
because I had a software company
and I quit on my business partner
I didn't know what to do I didn't know
what to do next I was making no money
I'm making 300 bucks a month I'm
struggling I'm suffering I I'm trying
I'm working hard every day and I just I
don't know what to do I don't know what
to do I don't know what to do help me
please I tried everything everything
that I could think of and nothing seemed
to be working and I was tired of being
broke and tired of being tired and tired
of not having results I'm tired of
having sex I was just I was I was beaten
down
I was tired
I had to find a different way
and so I quitted my business partner
it was the worst day of my life and then
I woke up the next day and said I can't
quit yet because if I do I'm going to
regret it
but I can't keep going the way that I'm
going I have to find a different way to
stand and so I said you know what
somebody's figured this out somebody's
figured this out somebody had to figure
this out who's figured this out who's
built the software company and the first
person I could think of was Bill Gates
and Microsoft well then I spent a ton of
time researching and understanding just
I was desperate I was hopeless I was
lost and I just thought Bill Gates
Microsoft and so I looked at how did
Bill Gates start Microsoft zero to one
right how did it get started how's
somebody who's super successful makes an
extra million dollars now or you know
how I might get an extra thousand
subscribers now it's not it's not as
relevant it's not as inspiring it's not
as helpful because there's a lot of
momentum that goes into it already so
but zero to one how did he get started
and I found out that he did it through
Partnerships
[Music]
found people who was already targeting
his target audience and he partnered
with them
partnership in terms of they own a part
of Microsoft but they they made a deal
together
and so Microsoft's big deal came with
IBM where every IBM IBM was the biggest
computer manufacturer at the time every
IBM computer shipped had Microsoft
software on it IBM had a new computer
they wanted to get it out to the market
they needed some great software for it
an operating system Microsoft came along
and helped them and so every IBM shift
had Microsoft software on it
like wow that's great and that blew up
the company that was like their giant
momentum moment but Microsoft is already
a seven million dollar company I think
when they made that deal
so how did they go from zero to seven
well same thing Partnerships their very
first partnership came with a company
called mits they had this device called
the Altair and it was on the cover of um
of a magazine and Bill Gates and Paul
Allen his business partner saw it and
they said if mits is going to come up
with the Altair
they need software for it
let's write to them and say that we can
we can do the software
and uh they said okay cool yeah come on
I'd love to see your software now this
is a little maybe sneakier underhanded
Bill Gates had not written the software
for you he didn't even have his hands on
on one of the midsole tears he's coding
it without having a device and without
having it ready and luckily by the time
he gets to them in the meeting it
actually worked right so that's a lot of
risk and that's a lot of staking your
reputation uh a guess on yourself and
your ability and hoping that it's going
to work out maybe a little too risky for
me but it was still the concept of
Partnerships who was already targeting
my target audience your target audience
and instead of trying to go after
customers one by one by one how can you
work with somebody who if they told
people about you it would reach 10
people at a time or 100 people at a time
or a thousand people at a time or a
million people at a time right how can
we make that happen
and so I look to my own business like
okay we sell scientific software who
else sells scientific not software but
other products that I can make some kind
of partnership with and and the first
company that I connected with was in the
UK
and I messaged them to say hey we've got
this company we've got the software
do you want to represent us in Europe
and I forget which markets we looked at
but UK in a couple other countries do
you want to represent us in Europe
because our software is great it works
but we we you know the customer support
and language differences and time zone
differences would you like to be our
partner in the UK and they said yes how
do we get started
I was nervous I was sweating I was
trying to figure out oh my gosh I got my
first potential deal here I'm I'm how
old I'm 20 at the time ish
um
and I say okay there's an uh there's a
there's an upfront commitment of
Thirteen and a half thousand dollars
they had to pay us thirteen and a half
thousand dollars by the time I'm making
300 bucks a month so I guess that's kind
of my bold little my bold my bold
statement or my bold commitment like
Bill Gates so you got to pay me 13 and a
half thousand dollars up front and I I
remember pressing send on the email and
uh
sweating nervous I don't want to lose
this deal you know finally got somebody
at the table and I said yes
they said yes
crazy they said yes and and then the
money hit our bank account like oh my
gosh thirteen hundred thousand dollars
this is crazy
it doesn't seem like a lot of money now
but man I felt like I won the lottery I
felt rich
and more important than just the money
was that something worked you know
momentum finally like something anything
was actually having an impact it's crazy
and uh I had a strategy that I could I
could apply I could go after other
companies and that's what I did like I
closed more and more and more deals more
of these partnership deals all based off
of Bill Gates's strategy right so again
I haven't met Bill Gates I haven't told
in this story yet
but the way that he built Microsoft
became an inspiration for me to build my
my company at least in the early days
and I got our company off the ground
and certainly get some results
and so one of you don't know what to do
you model success you find the person
who's done the thing it gives you hope
it gives you inspiration and it also
gives you specific strategies now it may
not fit a hundred percent right
I had to research Bill Gates I had to
see how he got started I had to see his
first deals and my deal wasn't exactly
the same deal that he signed but it's
close enough and all I really needed was
was the idea was a strategy to get
started and it saved my company saved my
business I mean I don't know if I didn't
do that I might have some job right now
that I hate honestly like I just quit on
my business partner
I was afraid I was going to live in the
regret of not knowing
and
I was just lost guys I was just lost but
I knew that if I stopped now that I I
would look back on that moment and say
what if I just kept going
and if I didn't find that strategy I
don't know what I would have done
honestly probably at some job that I
hate
it's crazy how these little little
shifts little moments
and make such a giant difference in your
life and so hopefully this video can
help inspire a little moment for you
so if you surround yourself with your
Heroes you look at the people who are
doing the thing that you want to do and
be around them more and study their
success it gives you the hope and the
motivation that it's possible
and hopefully it also gives you the
specific strategies and what you can do
so you can accomplish your goals as well
the fastest way to build your business
to get the right ideas to grow is to
model success rule number nine is get a
role model the thing that always helped
me make breakthroughs was getting a role
model and and learning from somebody
else and every time whether it's my
first business or getting started out on
YouTube with YouTube it was Steve and
finally listening to my agent Steve that
I started to grow and I did five years
like I'm in year five of my YouTube
channel I'm I still have 2 000
subscribers right so it's like I it took
if this was not an overnight success if
people want to see my growth I put it on
the website like year over year how how
much I grew or you know how much I grew
which is like nothing so uh we're not
naturally talented and anytime I try to
do something by myself it just didn't
work but whenever I sought out Role
Models mentors even virtually even
listening to watching videos reading
books Etc
I would I would have success so I just
wanted to try to share that more with
the world and when I meet somebody with
Integrity you know like like you it's
like man like we got to get Chucks up to
the world dude what how is this guy not
making content I know number 10 the last
one before some very special bonus Clips
is create a unique life I think you
should have a hard time explaining what
you do
like I think I think if you I think if
you don't have a hard time explaining
what you do then you hate your life like
then you you you're living inside an
easy to Define box and you're not happy
there and and not a masculine feminine
thing that's just a human thing so you
should have a hard time it's good it's
good if you have a hard time explaining
what you do means you're expressing
yourself and you're creating a unique
life right which is the goal for all of
us
um in terms of you know energy I think I
think how I approach it is less of like
a shield you know and trying to fight it
and hold it back and like you can't come
in and more of a dance and and some
dance Partners you dance with and go a
long way and some you you drop off and
move on right and so I'm less concerned
about the doing as much as you know why
I'm here I don't know what we're talking
about yeah there's no like preset list
of questions like Eric you have to talk
about this or I'm not coming on you know
like I don't know what we're going to
talk about and I'm dancing with the with
what where you're throwing up it's like
your your itching and I'm catching and
I'm throwing the ball back to you and
this is our dance in every dance is
unique and different and you get a
chance to express yourself a little bit
differently and sometimes that dance
last five minutes or may last a lifetime
and so I just see myself kind of that's
how I navigate through it is
if you're always kind of resistant and
fighting you're always stressed out and
full of anxiety and and always in
protection mode and that when you're
deep in protection mode you're not
you're not in a creative space ready to
make something amazing and abundant
right and so it's like okay I'm gonna
that doesn't work for me I'm I'm moving
on to the next dance and she's kind of
dancing through the energy and the more
you can actually feel it the first step
is awareness it's great that you even
caught it because you're feeling like
stressed out and overwhelmed but it's
like you don't know why okay well now we
get a sense of why but now you get to
choose a different dance partner
and that's how I see it and we're just
dancing down down the path
when you are accountable to other people
you are more likely to follow through
whether it's in entrepreneurship whether
it's in personal development whether
it's working out or working on yourself
when you are feeling like somebody else
is counting on you besides you you're
way more likely to follow through think
about going to the gym right you may not
like going to the gym
you may find reasons to put off going to
gym maybe it's early morning maybe
you're tired you didn't sleep well last
night your muscles still hurt from
yesterday all sorts of reasons and
excuses to come up with but if you know
that somebody else is going to be there
your friend is going to be there waiting
for you
you're way more likely to follow through
because now it's not just about you I
created a challenge inside my Movie
Makers program and movement makers is a
program I created to help thought
leaders experts who want to build up
their following and want to get their
message up to the world you got a big
message in here let's go to the world
and you train with me but you also get
to connect with each other and I was
frustrated that people were not making
enough content you've got such a big
message such a big potential voice your
story matters and people were not making
enough content and everybody was living
not everybody but a good chunk of people
were living inside the typical reasons
we all come up with right too busy I
don't know what gear to use I I don't
like how I look on camera my videos suck
over and over and over you know the same
reasons and so I decided to do something
a couple months ago that was different I
said you know what we are going to do a
challenge because the thing that's
missing is momentum
you guys have the heart and the soul and
the care just like
if you ever meet anybody in Movie Makers
it's just good people
just
um some of the nicest friendliest most
caring most giving people that I've ever
met you've got everything
you're just missing momentum
you're just not pulling that up there
because there's there's too many there's
too much blockage in your head
you need momentum
and so out of that frustration I came up
with the momentum Challenge and my goal
with the momentum challenge was
for them to make content but not just
make content actually
create the content in a way that can
generate business for them so
the challenge was structured in five
pieces of the content one was a solo
video and the theme was momentum so you
have to make a solo video on momentum
two is three collaboration videos with
other people in Movie Makers so you need
to do an interview with somebody and
collaborate on the theme of momentum
and then the third thing was to do a
lead magnet on momentum so lead magnet
basically implies that you create a PDF
or you create a unlisted video that you
can share in return for people giving
you their email address so they email
you you get you give them the PDF and
now they're on your email list and you
can use that to continue to build the
relationship and ultimately work with
them hopefully in some capacity right
where you're serving caring and making
money in the process too
so that's a challenge
and whoever's in
you have the whole month to do it
and at the end of the month whoever
completes the challenge
we're gonna do a clubhouse live
altogether and celebrate
I didn't know how it would go
you know like I hope I hope people would
take me up on it but it's easy to have a
lot of excitement at the beginning right
every have you ever been excited by
something at the beginning and then
pretty quickly in you fall off the
tracks right has that ever happened to
you we're talking about a month here
it's not just make one video today it's
you got to stay consistent for a month
you got to make five pieces of content
in a month and for a lot of people
didn't know how to do collaborations and
never done an interview with somebody
else for a lot of people that didn't
know what a lead magnet was or how to
make one or how to save a PDF or how to
set up a landing page how to do all the
tech behind the scenes right and those
are the excuses that they were
holding on to for why they couldn't win
in their own business but now it's being
forced now you have to do it and I
didn't know how well it would work out
and
fortunately it went insanely well
people had some of the best conversation
of their lives people finally got the
tech side of their business figured out
with landing pages and Lead magnets
people started forming alliances and
Partnerships and cooperations and joint
ventures with each other that I'd never
even anticipated or seen
why because they were committing to each
other
because now it wasn't just about doing
it for themselves it was about doing it
with somebody
and here's what's important it's not
just doing it by yourself or for
somebody
it's doing it with somebody that makes a
big difference because if you're
watching this channel you're probably
heart driven entrepreneur right that's
why I love you it's why you're here
you're a heart-driven entrepreneur you
want to serve you want to make money you
want to have an impact right it's not
just about the dollars but also putting
something positive out into the world
that you're proud of whether it's making
content like this or products or
Services you want to serve you are built
to serve it's why you're here and I love
that
and so you can connect to the mission
and the service because you're doing it
for somebody right you're doing it for
your audience you're doing it for your
customers you're doing it for the people
who are going to consume what you're
creating
that's very different though than doing
it with somebody because most
entrepreneurs and and this is a good gut
check or look in the mirror for yourself
most entrepreneurs are doing it by
themselves even if you have a team you
still feel like you're doing it by
yourself there's nobody who actually
gets what you do does that sound
familiar
do you feel like you're kind of alone on
this people who support you in my cue
you want but they're not in the same
boat they're not trying to do what you
do they don't know how to help besides
giving some words of encouragement
do you feel like you're doing it by
yourself and man is it hard to do
something that's hard when you're by
yourself then that's where you need the
mental toughness and the discipline and
the scheduling and the calendar and the
and you do hard things
and one of the best hacks to make sure
you actually follow through is you have
some accountability
and not just somebody to just to hold
your feet to the fire to say Hey you
know
what are you doing you know you don't
need a boss
what you need to feel like you're doing
this with people
that you're doing your thing but with
others
and I think that's where the movement
makers challenge just really played out
super well is that now all of a sudden
people are booking collaborations with
each other and they know what to talk
about where before they wouldn't they
wouldn't book an interview because they
didn't know what questions to ask
people are now helping each other with
their landing pages and Lead magnets
where in the past they would tell
themselves I don't know the tech I'm too
confused I need to hire somebody but I
have no money to hire somebody and now
all of a sudden they're getting it done
now it's happening we're months or a
year might have gone by and they still
hadn't done it now all of a sudden
there's momentum happening
why because they committed to somebody
else and because they committed to the
group
that they want to complete this thing
and then the celebration when we did our
our clubhouse at the end of the month
the stories and the emotion was just so
amazing it became movement makers
started as me sharing a message I'm
going to teach you how to XYZ and it
became so much more about the family and
the community and the connection that
really people are following through not
just because of the ideas that I'm
giving them but because they have a
group of people that they're doing this
thing with
so find your own group
you know or find one person I have a
something I remind myself of constantly
that I like to collect good people
I want to find good people I want to be
around good people I want to be around
the people who fill me up who make me
feel like I'm worthy I can do great
things make me energized I leave them
feeling better about myself than than
when I came in I want to be around those
people and when I find somebody like
that I want to I want to fight to find
more time with them
and as an introverted chai person that
can be really difficult and awkward and
I'm still afraid to ask for help and I
probably still don't do that enough
somebody I there's a speaker who I spoke
at his event and uh he's like how can I
help you like I don't know I'm here to
serve you know I wanted to help no
problem you know but and he wrote back
said no I I owe you like how can I help
you and and it's still something I'm
working on and doing a better job and
asking for help because I'll default to
him
find the solution myself don't want to
don't want to burden people you know
it's the story that is in my head that I
need to fix but when you can find people
to do something with when you are on
your path and you feel alone and you're
struggling and the motivation isn't
there but then you know that somebody
else is on the same Journey with you
you're so much more likely to follow
through
so I encourage you not to do this alone
not to live life alone not to run your
business alone that you'll have a
greater degree of Joy Of Happiness of
impact of service of momentum of of
progress of results
when you have people
even one person
who you feel like you're doing this with
so don't
try to be the hero all the time and feel
like you have to do everything yourself
don't think well I'm doing this for
people and that that's enough
make it a goal
of yours
that in the next 30 days you're gonna
find somebody who's gonna help hold you
a little bit accountable and you're
gonna hold them accountable too you're
giving just as much as you're taking
and together you're going to create
something amazing it's it's a true
scenario where one plus one equals 14.
U plus them equals tremendous growth for
both of you
you don't have to do this alone
get somebody to help you stay
accountable I think we play small by
default I think
man we are capable of so many amazing
things and we're constantly living in
fear and excuses and reasons why we
can't do something and we we haven't
trained in us from a young age our
parents our family our friends our
teachers think about who did you learn
about life from probably people who
didn't like their own life you know who
did you learn about careers from
probably people who did not have a great
career you know who barely are enjoying
what they're doing in their work and
they're living in scarcity mindset of
this is all I can do and that's what
we've learned from and you know guidance
counselors at school do they love what
they're doing I mean I think this is a
huge problem and we're stuck living
small and living scared and living as a
result way below our potential of what
we could do and who we could help
I I think it's a big problem I think
lack of belief is the world's number one
problem it's what I wake up every day
trying to do trying to help trying to
create and so how do you how do you get
out of it well I think the starting
point is being around the people who are
living and doing the things that you
want to do I think the way to 10x your
results is not to 10x your effort
sometimes it is especially the very
beginning sometimes the answers just do
more work but once you're at your Max
Capacity you you get to a point where
you can't actually 10x your work anymore
it's changing your mindset it's getting
new leverages busting through limiting
beliefs because
just working harder will not be the
answer anymore right is it working hard
or working smarter well it's both
right you have to working hard is is
your entry to the game
nobody wants without working hard in
anything you have to work hard but
there's lots of people who work hard who
who never accomplish their goals who
don't end up succeeding or winning
because they're not working smart so
it's a it's always a mix of both and so
if you're not working hard then you
don't have a shot but assuming you are
working hard and you want a 10x again
then it's a shift in mindset and a shift
in living beliefs so how do you identify
the living beliefs how do you figure out
where it's holding you back how do you
break through the Paradigm and hit a new
level a lot of it is environmental
the
current thinking that you have was
environmental it's your parents and your
family and your guidance counselor and
teachers and family Etc that's
environmental you've adopted their
beliefs and unfortunately a lot of them
are
negative limiting beliefs there's
probably some that a lot that are very
positive but a lot of them you've
adopted that that actually don't serve
you anymore for what you're capable of
and where you want to go especially
what's possible now in today's
environment so the shift is in a new
environment to start to surround
yourself with the people who are like
the people who you want to be
who believe the thing that you want to
believe and whoever's more confident
wins and so if you're around people who
are deeply confident that the thing that
they're after is possible or they've
already gone and accomplished it if they
deeply believe it and you just kind of
don't believe it they'll pull you into
the land of belief because they they are
more confident in their belief than you
are in the disbelief and so it's finding
the people who are living the life that
you want or at least aggressively
chasing it down they will motivate you
inspire you to want to go and live your
life as well so well how do we do that
right I mean it'd be great to be able to
hang out with Warren Buffett and Elon
Musk and all these people every day but
you know we can't so how do you do it
well
step one I think is just through content
it's why I make so many videos on all of
my channels is why I've stayed
consistent over a decade of making
content why because
I think when you are around the people
even just visually even just through a
computer screen or a cell phone it
starts to shift your beliefs and your
mindset and what you can do even for me
I make these videos for myself so that I
can be around John Ashraf and Warren
buff and Elon Musk and Oprah Winfrey Etc
because they inspire me to want to be
bigger looking at Elon Musk is an
example the news of the day right now as
I'm recording this video is he's looking
at buying Twitter
and when somebody asked me yesterday on
Instagram do I think Elon Musk will buy
Twitter
I said no I don't think you'll buy
Twitter but
it's probably not a good idea to
underestimate Elon Musk
just in general right you know lots of
people have underestimated him and he's
proven them wrong many many many times
and I just like the thinking
you know one of the things I love about
Elon Musk is
whenever I watch his stuff it challenges
me to think bigger
why would Elon Musk it logically be
thinking through it if you're if you
were running Tesla uh in SpaceX would
you have thought about buying Twitter
would that enter the realm of
possibility you know like this is the
difference between
small thinking and expansive thinking
like in his world it makes sense
and he wants to have a backup plan for
the planet whenever I think I'm thinking
big
Elon Musk is trying to have a backup
plan for the entire planet I realize I'm
still thinking way too small and the
point of that is not
um to beat yourself down like oh I'm not
as big a thinker or as Elon Musk right A
lot of people say comparison is a thief
of joy and a lot of people will
get off of social media because they're
comparing themselves to others I think
comparison can be a fantastic tool I
think it can be amazing because when you
are
running with
people who only make you feel good about
yourself but based off of their smaller
accomplishments then you stay stuck and
you stay a big fish in a small pond I
think competition is amazing but using
it in a positive way as opposed to
looking at someone like Elon Musk and
saying oh he's so much smarter than me
he thinks so much bigger than me I suck
I'm never going to be able to do that
look at it hey this is what's possible
there's not that big a gap between you
and Elon Musk it shows that it's
possible that you could do it too if he
can do it then you can do it
you came from South Africa and
immigrated to Canada then immigrated to
the United States he had a father who he
calls a Monster who beat him he had his
friends bully him and push him
downstairs at school like he had
he had all sorts of pain and Trauma and
struggles in his early life and he if he
can overcome that to get to where he's
at I see it as so can you and I see the
comparison as a opportunity that when
you see somebody else do something it
makes you feel a lot more confident that
you can do it too and so just use it in
a positive way instead of a negative way
so whenever I see someone like Elon Musk
it's a challenge to myself and looking
at him trying to buy Twitter it's like
huh what should I be doing you know it's
easy to get stuck in the same in the
same Groove but the groove can also be a
rut in that
you're getting slow growth and improving
where it could be a lot more expensive
it could be having exponential growth if
you change your environment to be around
the people who have expansive thinking
right so step one is just through
content through through aspirational
mentors is what I call them and Elon
Musk and John Azeroth Oprah Winfrey
people who who you may never meet but
you can still learn a heck of a lot from
step two was to then try to go to some
events that change up your environment
right if we're a product of our
environment then if you're always stuck
in the same habit the same house the
same routine the same environment then
it's going to constrict the thinking
have you ever noticed when you go on
vacation you come up with some great
ideas why well you've changed your
environment you've been influenced by
new things and it leads to more
expensive thinking so doesn't mean you
have to go take a vacation to the beach
or something this week but but what are
some changes you can make to your
environment what are some conferences or
events you can go to to be around the
people who think the way that you want
to think to inject some newness some
creativity some ideas into you that will
have you come back a stronger Bolder
more courageous person because you've
broken some of the chains of the rut
that you're in that things that used to
make sense like yeah that that that
makes sense for me to keep doing all of
a sudden you go away to a vacation a
conference an event you come back I
wanna you ever gone away and come back
and wanted to be
a different person wanted to be working
on new projects new goals come with new
ideas I get ideas all the time when I'm
traveling just just think about if
you're just constantly stuck it doesn't
mean you have to go travel on vacation
it may mean you take up salsa dancing it
may mean you try a new hobby take that
idea that you've got and just go go to
it look at any events that are happening
in your city meetup groups conferences
clubs that you can join and be part of
to meet new people and take on a new
interest and I promise you they may not
all work out in terms of this is my next
career move but it leads somewhere it's
a part of who you are you take the
learnings and the lessons from that and
it'll make you a better person a better
entrepreneur and you'll find a creative
way to mix things together I think if
Steve Jobs who started Apple who dropped
out of University because he wasn't
enjoying the classes and he dropped in
on calligraphy classes drawing like text
and letters for fonts which made no
sense like why are you dropping out of
this really practical school and
material to then sit in on calligraphy
when are you ever going to use
calligraphy it made no sense but he was
interested in it and what ended up
happening was when he's when he started
the apple and he created the Macintosh
it had the most fonts it wasn't just
boring computer fonts there were a bunch
of different fonts that he could use uh
that people could then use in their word
processing Etc and it was the most
beautiful uh computer at the time with
with unique fonts why people because he
pulled from his experience in his
calligraphy classes and how he describes
it is you can't connect the dots looking
forward to only backwards he didn't know
going to the calligraphy class at you
know what in five years I'm going to
start a company and I'm going to have
beautiful fonts as a part of it he was
just interested in calligraphy so he he
went to the class not knowing how it
ever working out but trusting that the
dots would at some point align in the
future right so looking back it makes
sense oh this and this and this all the
line to get me to where I'm at but he
wouldn't have known that unless he
dropped out of school and dropped in on
the calligraphy class so it's changing
the environments being a part of new
things it's it's not just staying stuck
in the same habit the same routines and
and same thing you're doing constantly
and that will inject newness that will
then allow you to be more creative and
create amazing opportunities for your
next goals so step one is to be around
aspirational mentors to be around the
people like an Elon Musk Oprah Winfrey
Etc watching videos content interviews
podcasts books that make you feel better
stronger more courageous step two is to
get out of your comfort zone and go go
to things physical things travel more
take take on classes say yes go to
conferences and events just so that you
expose yourself to new ideas and
opportunities and come up with fresher
ideas of what you could do with your
life and step three is to to actually
have humans in your life who you're
around who make you want to push and do
more and be better and this mean I hey
if you're hanging out with Elon Musk
amazing that's awesome you're probably
not doing that but who can you hang out
with who are on the same similar path as
you and that's where I love groups like
mover makers that I created for Thought
leaders but you know it's not Movie
Maker is something else but being around
other people who are doing the thing who
believe in this in the same thing if
you're if you're trying to run more join
our running club you're trying to work
out more you're going to join a gym if
you want to be a thought leader join
mover makers if you're like join a club
or a group where you can feel like
you're not doing this alone where you
can talk to people about the journey
that you're going on will they'll
understand you and not look at look at
you like you're some kind of alien like
your family or friends might like what
are you talking about what are you
getting into right join relevant Discord
groups like be a part of a community
because it's probably the biggest
mistake I made early on in my life I was
doing everything all by myself I had I
had business partners I guess but I felt
isolated I felt alone I didn't have
friends had nobody to talk to and
I really really struggled so find other
people who are on this journey that you
can do it with because when you feel
like you're doing it with other people
and you're not alone you'll be a lot
more productive a lot more effective and
have a lot more fun as well as well your
environment is keeping you where you are
your environment has been perfectly
designed to keep you exactly where you
are right now the people you listen to
the media that you consume the habits
that you do daily all of them all of
them are designed to keep you exactly
where you are so if you want to raise
your game if you want to raise your life
you need to raise your environment I've
changed a lot over the course of having
this YouTube channel the people who've
known me the best and the longest
especially in the past two to three
years have said Evan you've changed a
lot for the better you've evolved you're
more confident you have more more Poise
you're a better speaker you you're
pushing the boundaries more you've
changed what happened
how do I get that for myself right
people wanted it as whenever you are off
growing and learning and evolving other
people they want it they want a taste of
it they want to do it too because we are
not designed to just photocopy Our Lives
over and over and over again so how did
I get it I paid more attention to my
environment I paid more attention to my
daily routines I paid more attention to
the people that I hang around with it's
important so looking at my physical
environment right look at the look at
this office look at the people behind me
this all means something to me looking
at the new design that I've had here
below putting things like my neck braces
it's down below you can't really see it
but this inspires me I walk into this
every day
my YouTube videos the channel I create
for myself
that the people that I profile I'm
learning from I feel like I have garyvee
in my head I have Oprah Winfrey in my
ear I've got Elon Musk tell me what to
do pushing me to try to get better I
hear these people talking about you have
to be courageous you have to be bold you
have to believe in yourself more and
when I feel myself being nervous about
something boom boom boom boom boom it's
a push that I have to do it
and so I've designed my life I've
designed my environment to help push me
to get to the next step
and it's it's scary and it should be
where am I going next I don't know I'm
still a work in progress but the more
that you are around people who push you
who make you better who make you want to
do more who pull you up to their level
guess what the more you're gonna get
there the alternative is you're stuck
where you are you stick with your
friends you stick with the media you
consume you stick with the habits that
you have and listen if you love your
life awesome if you're good then you're
good then then
don't change anything but if you're not
happy with where you're at if you know
you're capable of more especially for
the entrepreneurs you know you're
capable of more you know you have a gift
you know you're a genius you know what's
in here needs to get out there can have
a huge impact and help a lot of people
if you feel like that's you then you
need to make a drastic change to your
environment you need to change it
because everything you're doing right
now is keeping you on the path that
you're on maybe there's been some growth
if you look at who you were five years
ago compared to now you've grown if
you're watching this channel you've
grown right you've made some changes but
is it drastic enough like are you proud
of where you're at look at where you've
come from in the past year two years
five years are you proud of where you're
at and are you comfortable with that
same level of growth for the next five
years if not if you think I want more I
want to help faster I want to have a
bigger impact faster quicker
then the fastest way to do it is to
change your environment so that's you
I'm going to give you a three-step
process that I think will help step
number one is cut out negativity just
cut out the people who don't serve you
sometimes those are friends that you've
had from kindergarten or high school or
university
you're in the Friendship out of
convenience now there's a lot of people
who you might need to let go of you
might need to just let them go They
don't serve you anymore you've you've
walked your parallel path together and
now they've gone out well they've
probably just stayed here while you've
gone out here
They don't serve you anymore and it
doesn't mean you have to be a mean
person or cold or rude you're just not
on the same path anymore and a lot of
people fight that because you're worried
about finding new friends or being
around new people and so you stick with
these people who don't serve you anymore
and that's a mistake because they're
keeping you where you're at because
their negativity they're complaining
their unwillingness to change their
pessimism their laziness they're not
chasing down goals that that becomes
toxic even if you're trying to be a
beacon even if you're trying to be the
person who pulls everybody up
if all you're doing is trying to pull
other people up and there's nothing
pulling you up
you're going to be limited for life
when I went to the Tony Robbins event
the second one where he invited me to
come as his guest
at the end of the first day or second
day you're asked to go do a fire walk
and the whole idea is to do something
scary well I went home to my Airbnb at
the time and and I did the scary thing I
didn't I skipped the fire walk at Tony's
event to go home and do the real fire
walk which was letting go of some people
that that I had been around for in some
cases a decade plus that this doesn't
serve me anymore I'm I'm doing this just
out of convenience instead of something
that's actually helping me grow and so I
need to shed this skin so that I can be
reborn like this is new skin none of you
that's trying to grow
right you're trying to become a
butterfly
but you're forced to stay a caterpillar
you don't want that so you gotta let go
of the negativity sometimes that might
be family and with family maybe maybe
you should cut out some of your family
members from your life maybe maybe
that's that sounds drastic but maybe you
should a less drastic version of that is
just don't talk about some things limit
access if you know that career talk is
always going to cause problems with your
family then don't talk about your career
see I don't I'm not talking about that
and stand up for yourself
at what point is this your life this is
your life your parents your the people
around you they love you they want you
to have success they just they're from a
different era they're a different
generation they don't know what's even
possible right now
what they did if you're 21 their life at
21 was totally different your parents
life when they were your age was totally
different
they don't understand what's available
right now and so even though their
messages is out of love likely like your
parents probably love you
they just don't understand what's
possible
and you can't blame them
this is your fault now you need to
accept responsibility for where you're
at and limit the conversations limit
exposure cut out the negativity from
your life it's really hard for a seed to
grow when it's in a toxic waste dump
and that becomes a choice you know a
seed where it gets planted doesn't
really get the choice of where it gets
planted but you you get to choose you
get to change your environment so choose
powerfully and cut out the negativity
from your life step number two is then
seek out optimism seek out positivity
seek out things that make you grow that
make you want to learn that make you
want to push yourself right I have my
channel that's really helped me that
every day I wake up and I'm surrounded
by positivity and optimism and belief
and things that drive me forward that
even if I've I've had a rough sleep or a
bad day or or whatever it might be I see
Steve Jobs right next to me staring me
down I have my parents behind me looking
at me encouraging me putting belief back
in me I've got videos to go to that will
build me up I've got my believe playlist
of music that I listen to that will
change my state and bring me back to a
place of optimism positivity what is it
for you
is it people do you need to be around
people physically can you go to meetup
groups can you go to the library or
coffee shop can you go join some
entrepreneur circles can you become part
of a co-working place can you be around
people
that that are positive that are
energizing for you or can it be your
physical environment right or can it be
your habits and your routines or can it
be the the media you consume what are
you consuming what are you watching on
TV
or on Netflix is it is it entertainment
are you just shutting off your life to
try to forget about your problems or
just be entertained or you're trying to
educate yourself to build a better life
this is this is one of the fundamental
problems in the world right now
people they have problems you have
problems most people choose
entertainment as a way to forget about
their problems instead of Education as a
way to make their problems better do you
want to shut off the world
and and laugh at somebody else's expense
and watch big brother and see man that
person's life sucks or do you want to go
build a better life for yourself
most people don't want to do the work to
actually build a better life I hope that
you do because that's how you actually
end up being happy do you want to numb
it with drugs do you actually want to
build a better life for yourself and in
Step number three is scheduled for
success
schedule for Success so what are your
daily habits what's in your calendar
what is the thing that makes you feel
bold alive contagious you know optimism
what's the thing for me it's watching
videos for me it's going through my 5S
schedule so I start the day with singing
where I have videos that are on YouTube
that just their songs that make me want
to sing make me want to dance make me
want to move it's the fastest way to
change your state I wake up tired and
maybe low energy and then I put on music
and it and it changes my state and makes
me happy do that for yourself don't put
on music that matches your current mood
put on music that matches the mood that
you want to feel like and it's the
fastest way to just in a snap be able to
change yourself we all have music that
makes you bounce and come alive start
your day with that right that's part of
mine so singing then Sun I like getting
Sun going outside being in nature just
having sun on my face not just being
stuck inside all day especially in the
morning makes a big difference my third
s is sore so I want to do something
makes me feel bold and come alive and
for me where I love my phone here but
for me I share a message I want to share
a message you want to feel like the work
that I do has meaning and importance so
I think about somebody that I helped
yesterday and then I share a message on
Instagram and Snapchat and put it up
that helps me soar what do you need for
yourself then I sweat so I'll do a quick
workout and then I do something to scare
myself right now it's doing
um cold showers so I sweat and then I
take a cold shower and it's like and I
do difficult things that's my morning
routine right I called the five five and
a half s rule because
some days I'll start with a snuggle with
my wife in bed so we're seeing if that's
going to become like a 6S protocol but
at least it's five and a half right now
that's what makes me come alive you
might need something totally different
I'm okay with that that's amazing maybe
you need to meditate maybe you need to
pray maybe you need to pet your cat you
what is the thing that you need to do to
make you feel bold and alive and and
then schedule that in so that you're not
hoping one day that something happens
you're not hoping that you're gonna meet
the right person or hoping you're gonna
find the right video like demand
Excellence from yourself demand
positivity and optimism from yourself
every day because if you did if you were
bold coffin optimistic positive every
morning if you created that system for
yourself man what could you accomplish
in a year can you imagine
if you did something every morning that
made you feel bold and confident if you
felt bold and confident every morning
for the next year imagine the life and
business that you're gonna have it's
crazy it's wild right so you have to
create that you have to schedule for
success success will come from your
habits so look at your calendar what are
your habits and if you did these habits
would it lead to you becoming a success
you don't have to stay stuck
when you come up with a great idea that
in your heart you know this is the thing
that I want to do and then almost
instantly all the negative voices come
in your head as to why you can't do it
and why someone like you will never be
able to do this thing
you're stuck
keeps you frustrated keeps you knowing
that you're capable of more and being
too afraid to go take the action and
until you can break that pattern of
negative self-talk
nothing will happen
and so we're gonna fix that in this
video I think as soon as we come up with
ideas
it's not even our friends it's not even
the people around us it's us it's us
telling ourselves that we suck that we
can't do it that we're not good enough
that we're not capable that it's not
gonna happen
we land into procrastination mode and
you can call yourself a perfectionist it
has to be perfect
but perfectionism is still just fear
fear just fear that you're not good
enough feel that it won't work out of
fear of being seen fear of not being
seen and it keeps you stuck
when I procrastinate on things even like
making videos
yeah I've made I don't know how many
twelve thousand thirteen thousand
fourteen thousand videos some crazy
number of videos and yet every time
before I sit down to make the videos I
procrastinate a little bit in today's
filming session I'm here at uh my wife's
Acupuncture Clinic she's inside getting
her acupuncture done I joined her
sitting in the car and it probably took
me
15 minutes
to get into
The Zone I know I'm gonna make the
videos I've developed the identity that
I'm gonna get get it done but I'm I'm
worried I want I want the videos to be
good I wanted I don't want to embarrass
myself don't want to let myself down
don't want to let you down if you're
disappointing people is my my biggest
fear I don't want you to feel like this
is wasting your time you ever had these
thoughts you know like you want to do
something and then you want it to be
good and you don't want to disappoint
people and so you him and you ha and you
procrastinate and then and then all of a
sudden the day is gone you haven't done
anything you know has that happened so I
try to keep it to 10 minutes 15 minutes
it is a little longer you should be like
five ten minutes took a little bit
longer 15 minutes today to get into
to get into the zone and you know what
happened the next thought was
what if I just check uh check and see
how my team is doing and and
because I want to feel valuable and
because I want to feel like I'm doing
something productive I want to get out
of the discomfort of not filming videos
and go check in on my team because that
would make me feel more productive like
no no no no
sit with it
we gotta we gotta change it we gotta go
we gotta make some content you're gonna
do this and make that first video so
even for me even for someone who's done
five figures of videos
every time I sit in front of the camera
to make a video the first one I
procrastinate I sit on it because I'm
afraid
and I don't want to disappoint people so
it's totally normal so if you feel like
whatever the thing is that you want to
do
you know you're capable of it you know
in your heart that it's something that
you want to create and then for some
reason you keep stopping you keep
procrastinating you keep staying stuck
that's normal you're not there's nothing
wrong with you it's not abnormal it's
100 everybody goes through it
the difference is how quickly can you
shift how can you get unstuck because
most people just stay stuck they stay
constipated
like all this all the stuff that has to
come out that's just not coming out
you're constipated you stay stuck so how
do you do it how do you shift it here
are a couple things that helped me that
I hope can help you number one is is
floss the first tooth take immediate
momentum you think about flossing
it's you know people don't want to floss
I mean my floss I've built a habit of
flossing twice a day most people don't
floss and the concept is just floss one
tooth and once you've floss one tooth
you'll floss the rats probably right
just get your running shoes on and go
for a walk and once you're walking
you'll probably do more than you know
the two minutes that you set yourself
into mind like just do two minutes so
for me is just make the first video
come on Evan just record the first video
so I recorded the first video and now
this is my second video in my filming
session and I'm already feeling better
it's like we're going we're vibing yeah
let's do this is amazing come on
just keep going just just go it's so
much easier to keep the momentum going
once you've built some momentum the
hardest step is the first step the
hardest step is just building that
initial momentum at the beginning once
you get going it's a lot easier to keep
going so just start don't don't make it
some big thing don't make it some giant
Endeavor that you have to go off and
Chase it's nice to have big goals and
big Ambitions and Big Dreams but
sometimes they're too big and then you
feel like you can't do it and you need
venture capital and you need a team you
need all sorts of things before you can
do anything on it it's great to have
that big goal and what are you gonna do
today
to build some kind of momentum
and once you start building that
momentum it's just so much so much so
much so much easier so the challenge for
today is just just find one small simple
easy way to get started that it doesn't
have to be amazing it doesn't have to be
great it's just the first step once you
get your first step it's so much easier
to take the second so that's why just
start building some immediate momentum
number two is change your state
one of the reasons why I like filming in
the car people ask why are you always
filming in your car I like I like being
out I like I like being out of the place
out of my home I like I like energy I
like nature I like being able to see
trees and and sunshine and have people
around you know I like I like that it
changes my state it's it makes it a lot
easier for me to go off and film when
I'm by myself so it's not just
um me talking to the camera if this
feels more conversational I don't know
it's all it's all just uh a head game
but it feels more it feels like I'm
talking to a friend hello how you doing
I'm Evan it feels it feels more
conversational and natural for me I like
having the sun on my face you know it
just feels better and so changing your
state can be a good way if you're in a
wherever you're at you know think
whether you're in your bed or in your
car or in your office or the dining room
table you know change your state move
around get up
you want to change the negative thoughts
start moving get up doesn't have to go
work out or do you know 100 jumping
jacks just get up and even get in some
fresh air getting out of the space that
you're thinking negatively in really
helps just changing your physical
location really really really really
really helps I promise you have you ever
had a uh you're thinking really
negatively
um you're procrastinating you're feeling
down and then you go for a walk and you
feel better or even just change your
room where you go to a different part of
the house or you go for a drive and then
you feel better like changing the
physical environment can really help you
get out of that funk that you're in
where while you're in that space you're
feeling
stuck and you can't move so change your
physical environment one little bonus to
that is music music I should have done
that today
music is the fastest way to change your
state so while I was sitting here in the
car for 15 minutes procrastinating
making these videos instead of thinking
hey I should go and check in on my team
and see how they're doing underneath
like logically that makes sense like
how's my team doing I'm being a good
boss you know good manager a good friend
I should check in on them see how
they're doing it's going to move my
goals forward of course because if
they're waiting on me for something
right logically all that makes sense
underneath it is just again the fear
that my videos won't be good enough so I
need to feel productive I need to feel
value valuable to myself I need to feel
worthy so I'm going to spend my time
there instead of making videos right I
should have put on music when that was
happening
instead of going to check out my team
which I didn't do but wanted to
uh I should have put on some music
like put on some music that makes you
move and you don't have to be the most
expressive dancer or singer just
anything that would get your head bobbin
or your foot tapping or your knee
bouncing just songs that make you come
alive and there's no one Perfect song
but whatever song gets you in the zone
even if you're feeling really low you'll
find yourself like having energy and
moving and it changes your state the
whole point is just to get unstuck and
to start building some momentum towards
what you say is what you want to do
right so music is the fast way to change
your state and then number three is I
would say have play bigger triggers
and play bigger triggers are the things
in your environment that remind you of
who you want to be
the things that you could put up the the
reminders on your cell phone background
on your desktop background the artwork
on your wall the things that you could
put in your life to remind you of who
you want to be so I'll share a couple of
them from my example in my office I have
five pictures on the wall and they all
tell a different story remind me of who
I want to be I've got Steve Jobs on the
wall who reminds me to be a Visionary
I've got AP giannini on the wall who's
my favorite entrepreneur of all time and
he reminds me to to believe in
um in the little guy and what I'm trying
to do I've got my parents on the wall
who remind me to believe in myself I've
got Howard Schultz on the wall who
reminds me to stand for something
important they've got Kanye on the wall
to remind me that the time is now that I
have to go do something now to be the
greatest Meme and
those pictures I picked with intention
and when I walk into my office they're
there and they remind me and I don't
have to do anything you know you set it
up once and it reminds me it reminds you
of who you want to be I walk in the
office there's my parents looking back
at me and telling me to believe in
myself the clothes that you wear right I
wear I wear this is my believe hoodie I
feel like I'm Batman I tell myself when
I put this on I'm Batman I'm a superhero
going to work fighting the crime of lack
of belief
commented on my hoodie yesterday's like
you're always wearing you're always on
brand you're always wearing your hoodie
it's like it's not just it's not just
when I show up to make videos this is
this is this is what I wear because I'm
a I'm a superhero going to work and when
I put this on in the morning it's like
I'm I'm I'm Batman going to work or uh
uh you know police officer going to work
it's like this is this is what I do
and
I'm a lot more
for me
productive and ambitious and bold when
I'm wearing this compared to when I'm in
my pajamas
until there's a conscious choice to say
okay what do I want to wear and so the
artwork on my wall the background on my
cell phone the computer screen
background the the things that I wear
right play bigger triggers
that you ideally just set it up once
and then it reminds you it's okay there
it is there's my trigger again there
there it is that this is who I want to
be this is who I want to be this is who
I want to be I'm around the things that
make me remember what I'm trying to do
because your brain will trick you to
stay small your brain will trick you to
stay stuck your brain will trick you to
say yeah you you can't do that and
here's all the reasons why
and you believe those reasons you
believe those reasons who are really
you're just afraid I'm just afraid I'm
afraid that we're not good enough we're
afraid they're going to be judged we're
afraid of disappointed people we're
afraid of not being loved we're afraid
that
we're going to be seen and gonna be made
fun of you know we're just afraid at the
end of the day you me everybody we're
just we're just afraid that the reason
why you're stuck is you're afraid and so
when you can learn to catch those
feelings
and when you can learn to uncover those
feelings and switch them say you know
what
I'm going to change my environment I'm
going to change my state I'm going to
change what I'm listening to I'm going
to change what I'm wearing I'm going to
change my mind and I'm going to go do
the thing to start building momentum
because the only thing you're missing is
momentum the only thing you're missing
is momentum you've got a great heart a
great Soul a great idea your idea is
worthy you're doing it for the right
reasons you want to serve you can do
this you can be in a totally different
place in 6 months and 12 months you can
it's possible you can your mission is
worthy and Noble and should happen and
you're the one to do it you you're the
one to do it
and it's not that you're not good enough
and it's not that you're not capable and
it's not that you can't do it at some
point you just don't have the momentum
momentum
you're just missing momentum
and so the next time you feel stuck
procrastinating not good enough
know that you can do it
and that all you need to do is take that
first step some businesses are just
easier to build on the scale than others
but some businesses have a high growth
market and some of them are slow growth
it doesn't mean that you can't win but
the opportunity is going to be much
different the upside is going to be much
different depending on the market that
you're going into
I love to say that a successful
entrepreneur is one who combines what
you love doing with the world as an
opportunity if you love doing it but
there's no opportunity or it's really
small then you've got a hobby it can be
really fulfilling hobby but it's when
you love doing it and there's a big
opportunity that's when you start to win
now if there's a big opportunity you
don't love doing it you're not going to
win either you can build an okay
business if there's a big opportunity
but you don't like doing it but only for
so long because then you're gonna quit
you're gonna hate your life because
you're waking up every day and doing
work that you don't like doing and
you're gonna quit this is where a lot of
entrepreneurs struggle they do one of
those two things they try to start a
business just around their hobby what
they're passionate about but there's no
Market opportunity they don't know how
to tie it into real demand so they never
build a business just a hobby on the
weekends any events or
they're just chasing the hot opportunity
and they don't care about the business
and so either way you're going to lose
in both those scenarios you win by doing
the work that you love
that has a big opportunity upside to you
as well I want to share two quick
examples uh that happened to me in the
past week that I think could be really
relevant and valuable one was a dear
friend of mine asked me what social
media platforms am I focusing on and
we're talking about Instagram because he
he wants to go more hardcore Instagram
want to know what I was doing on
Instagram and I said you know what right
now I'm not doing much on Instagram
you know I'm not spending a lot of my
effort my time my energy on Instagram I
love serving I love helping I love
getting a message out there I want to do
it in a way that has the biggest
potential or impact and reach in the
projects I'm working on so he said well
where are you spending your effort and
energy well YouTube was still number one
YouTube is number one because YouTube is
still the best place to get your message
across it has been for the past couple
years and it's only getting bigger more
people are going to YouTube for content
for Education it's only getting bigger
so YouTube is still number one but then
after YouTube where am I spending most
of my time
Twitter
and Discord Discord I think is the best
place to be for community and Twitter
it's surprising how how much Twitter has
picked up Twitter was one of the first
social networks I was on and I I not
left it but kind of ignored it for years
and now it's back it's back baby so I'm
spending a lot of my time on Twitter and
Discord and of course YouTube
and why well because that's where people
are that's where the impact is that's
where you get your message out and so I
don't care about the platform I care
about reaching people so you could spend
all day long working on on Instagram or
you could have spent all day long still
if you were working on MySpace creating
your account does Myspace still exist I
don't even know
it's just not a big opportunity
and so yeah again what do I care about I
care about helping entrepreneurs I care
about getting a message out there so
then it becomes using your head okay
where's the opportunity YouTube Discord
Twitter PS if you want to join my
Discord server it's free I'm there every
day Evan carmichael.biz come check us
out
example was I'm talking to a successful
entrepreneur who wants to move from his
big business that he's built tens of
millions of dollars in Revenue to
starting a business to help other
entrepreneurs get their companies going
and he's having a hard time getting this
thing off the ground that is having a
hard time monetizing it
and he's having a hard time getting
people to pay him for things
and I said well the immediate
opportunity you know if you have a long
Horizon great you'll you'll eventually
win because your brain will play out
you'll get better at them at the game
Etc but
the best thing you can do right now if
you want to monetize it is coach people
who are
inside of your industry that you have
domain expertise because what he's
coming out doing is just helping people
with personal development coming in
helping them believe in themselves
helping them overcome their living
beliefs you know uh helping them
fixed our mindset get their schedule
right all that stuff but then if they're
off building their own business
he's only adding one little piece now
imagine if you could add the tactical
information in the contacts as well as
the mindset and the motivation so
there's two entrepreneurs three
entrepreneurs that I invested into
recently Drew
Jeremy and Bo and these three guys
some of them had no experience I think
Jeremy had he was a stock boy at a
grocery store and you know he's mid six
figures Revenue 18 months later why well
because yes I'm giving him the belief in
the mindset and the motivation but I can
also give him contacts I can also make
introductions for him I can also give
him information about the industry to
know
what he's doing right and what he's
doing wrong and so when I'm looking to
make an investment into an entrepreneur
I want to be able to help them Beyond
just believe because I can get believed
anybody but whoever I want to give
believe to that had the highest impact
for Success it's going to be people who
I can give contacts to Jeremy does
YouTube Consulting there's people who
contact me all the time for YouTube
Consulting I don't want to do it
I don't want to be in that business so I
can give it to Jeremy perfect but if you
were a you know I don't know you were an
arborist can you see the trees I guess
not it's kind of blurry
um if you're an arborist I could help
you believe in yourself I can give you
some business model ideas but I can't
make contacts or introductions for you
and so you have to be smart about the
opportunities you take on
it has to be something that you
deeply deeply deeply care about
and then inside that find the
opportunity
because the market is moving and the
market hopefully is getting bigger and
if you're inside a growing market and
you love what you're doing that's a slam
dunk that's a home run for you so
what's the methodology now to help
figure that out well one you have to
start with what do you naturally just
love doing what do you love doing what
can you wake up and get what do you what
are you getting lost in where are you
spending your time what are you
daydreaming about don't not about the
result not about the cars and the yachts
and the whatever right not that that
that's a result what do you get lost in
the process of doing what industry do
you actually care about where are you
spending your time where are you
researching what doesn't feel like work
for you right so that's Step One is is
connecting to something that you're
actually passionate about not just
trying to make money right make money is
important but it's not step number one
figure out that idea next is okay how do
we turn that into a market opportunity
where is the business actually growing
that we can connect our our talents and
our passions to so if you love send if
you love sharing a message like my first
example great now be strategic about the
platform that you're going to pick
it used to be Instagram now it's YouTube
Twitter and Discord
if you love coaching people and
Consulting and investing in people great
connected to where you actually have
domain expertise and can make
introductions for people and take a
piece of their business as opposed to
just charging for the hour or just
helping people with mindset and not
actually introductions and tactics right
so you love the opportunity
it makes you come alive thinking about
it and
there's actually something for you to
grow right logically strategically is a
way for you to make money doing it when
you can combine those two things you
have a much much much much much much
higher degree of success I'm going to
substitute mission for purpose your
purpose is what you are here for your
purposes what do you wake up excited to
do your purpose is what's the impact
that you want to have on the world what
do you want to be known for what do you
want to create
your purpose is the thing that keeps you
going when when you want to quit when
you want to give up when you feel like
it's not happening fast enough when your
goals aren't enough to keep you going
what is the thing that keeps you going
it's your purpose to feel like what you
are doing today matters is Meaningful is
going to have an impact and
people have asked me somebody asked me
yesterday I was doing IG live and
somebody asked me how do you
how do you keep going you're one of the
most consistent people I've ever seen in
my life uh how do you keep going how do
you keep making videos well I feel like
it matters I'm living my purpose I don't
think what I'm doing is that unique
that's special I think everybody can do
it
it's it's within reach for everybody to
do it the problem is most people are
just chasing opportunity
and just trying to make a quick buck and
making money is very important it is
very important it's just not number one
number one is your purpose
if you woke up and felt like today
mattered that it was gonna mean
something to somebody you're gonna show
up in a totally different way you're
going to show up with more energy it's
going to be easier to say yes
I was making videos for years with
getting almost no views zero comments
why because I felt like what I was doing
mattered that if a hundred people saw my
video that's 100 people that's on my
video or if you're just chasing the end
goal if you're just chasing oh I need to
have a million subscribers or I need to
have X in my bank account
you stop you will quit because it gets
too hard
where if you actually felt like I'm
gonna show up today and I'm gonna do
something that matters and it's going to
change at least one person's life there
are some days when you feel like you can
change the world right there are some
days when you feel like I can do
anything I could change the world I'm
going to X right there are some days
when you actually feel that and it's
amazing and there are some days where
that feels too big and too scary and
your purpose feels too overwhelming and
and it should be it should be
aspirational it should be beyond your
reach it should not be something that
just gets solved in your lifetime it's
something that you want to swim forever
to climb forever to keep chasing down so
there are some days where it feels too
big and on those days don't stress about
it being too big worry about hey I'm
just gonna help one person for me when
I'm stressing out about making content
making videos
speaking on stage whatever else I'm
doing some days like I'm gonna change
the world today and other days is
I hope I can reach a few people with the
video
this is a Tuesday for me I record videos
on Tuesday every Tuesday I make content
into my calendar and it's always the
most
stressful day for me
in my week because I always want to make
the best that I can I want I want
today's video to be the best that I can
with what I've got
because I want to have an impact I want
I want hopefully this video and the way
that I say it and just hope that this is
the one that finally resonates with at
least one person The Hope isn't I need
this video to go get a million views or
I'm a failure the hope is
that for you maybe for you maybe you're
the one today
that the way that I say it
hits you in the right spot that pushes
you towards some kind of action to take
that thing that's been sitting inside
your heart that you've been sitting on
for a long time that you know you want
to do and get the permission get the
courage to actually go off and do the
thing
that's what purpose does for you
purpose demands that you grow into a
better version of yourself because you
won't do it just for yourself
if your goals are just purely selfish if
it's just to have money in your bank
account or buy a certain car or whatever
the goals just for yourself will not
sustain you through the long stretches
of bad times that it takes to go off and
actually build something meaningful the
thing that sustains you is feeling like
this is of Greater
service to other people than just me
Okay so
everybody has a purpose the purpose is
the thing that gets you going the
purpose is the thing that keeps you
motivated the person the purpose is the
thing that makes you want to do
something today how do you find it Well
finding it doesn't have to be a
difficult process I wrote about it in
built to serve I believe humans are
built to serve and finding your purpose
comes from your I call it your why and
your why comes in your pain your purpose
comes from your pain your purpose
it's not something that changes next
year or the year after or the year after
it's not it's not what's my purpose for
this year
that's a decent enough conversation even
figuring that out if you wanted to go
down that path what's my purpose for the
year it's already more self-awareness
than what 99 of the world has but that's
still not your life's purpose your
purpose is the thing that at 120 years
old you're still obsessed about my
purpose isn't to grow my YouTube channel
I don't know if I'll be doing YouTube at
120 years old that's too far away for me
to think about my purpose is to try to
solve the world's biggest problem which
is that people don't believe in
themselves enough and when I'm 120 years
old that will still be there and I will
still be doing whatever the the modern
technology is right if it's YouTube
amazing if it's VR something totally
different I'll be doing that because I
want to solve that problem
that's what I wake up every day trying
to do why well because the purpose comes
from my pain because what I struggled
the most with
me oh Nina brought some coffee we love
you Nina
look at the steam look at the steam I
bought this guy coffee and you bought
the homeless guy coffee he said it's his
birthday it's his birthday look at Nina
so special
spreading her purpose love it my purpose
came from my pain I struggled so much as
an entrepreneur
I felt the lowest
as a human I felt worthless I quit on my
business partner I thought it was never
going to work out I I just felt
incredible pain I felt lonely isolated
worthless
and I did quit on my business partner
and then luckily I came back the next
day and just decided I can't quit on
this yet and I'm still making all of
this content all of my material how many
years later let's see that was that was
when I was 19 20. I'm 41 now so 20 plus
years later still helping still making
content still going and it's going to be
another 80 years of doing this because
there are so many people millions of
people who are 19 year old Evan right
now struggling with the same thing
whatever you struggled with
think about in your life that the
deepest
most traumatic experience where you felt
worthless as a human being the most
painful emotionally moment that you had
to go through
and you barely made it you know you
didn't you didn't Triumph your way
through it you struggled but you made it
and now you're here and you're still not
where you want to be but you're way
further ahead than you used to be right
you right now could go back to you from
10 years ago five years ago seven years
ago and give some great advice
that's your purpose
to know that there are millions of
people right now who are currently the
person you used to be and they may not
make it through
they may not make it through like you
did you had the strength you had the
courage you had the strategies you found
the way and you made it through and they
may not and they need you they need your
voice they need your hope they need your
inspiration they need your message they
need you in a way that they won't listen
to me they won't listen to Tom bilyu or
Tony Robbins they won't listen because
they don't connect to us but they will
connect to you because you are like them
so it doesn't have to take you years to
figure out your purpose you don't have
to go to a retreat you don't have to go
meditate on a mountain you don't have to
hire a fancy business coach you don't
you have to you don't have to do
anything you already know it
you go back to the most painful moment
in your life
where you felt worthless as a human
being and then just deeply connect to
that and feel and know that there are
many people out there right now
who are that right now
and they have no hope and no guidance
and no leadership and no wisdom and they
feel stuck and they then they feel alone
they feel afraid they feel ashamed
they're not reaching out they're not
asking for help and they're going and
they're searching they're searching
they're going to YouTube they're going
to YouTube they're going to YouTube
they're going to YouTube how many times
you have to say that they're going to
Google they're going to Twitter they're
going to Facebook they're they're
searching they're searching for help for
answers
you could be the one that shows up
and if you actually felt that
[Music]
that on some days you could change the
world and on some days
you could change one person's life if
you actually felt that
you'll show up completely differently
finding your purpose and living it is
the thing that gives you the motivation
the strength the confidence to show up
one more day and keep going standing up
has changed my life not just standing up
for myself and standing up for what I
might believe in and the the
standing up what is it it's not
metaphysical the the the theoretical I
don't know but but actually standing up
like the physical standing up
going from sitting down like I am right
now in my car but to standing up has
changed my life stand-up desks are now a
huge uh Trend and a huge boost and and I
would definitely recommend checking some
of those out but when I first started
setting up was probably
wow I don't know maybe 20 years ago 15
years ago
I just found that when I was on the
phone and talking this is how it started
so I've been on I'm actually now on a my
office is a trampoline so I'm on a
stand-up trampoline desk I had to raise
my desk uh 10 inches so that the
trampoline could be underneath it and I
get 20 to 40 000 jumps a day on my
trampoline and went through three
trampolines last year because they broke
because most are not designed to be
jumped on that often but
trampolining while working might be a a
stretch for most people right now if you
ever see me and I'm doing an interview
and I'm on my main computer you might
see me
doing little micro bounces and I'm
trying to control it like hold it onto
the desk like don't bounce don't bounce
don't bounce because it can be it can be
annoying to watch on an interview but
for the most time I'm bouncing up and
down all day long on my trampoline now
why why did I start this well
15 20 years ago I just found that when I
was on the phone
and I was I was talking to clients I
would be better when I was walking
around I don't know if it's a nervous
energy or what but when I sat down it
was
less energetic less less like let's go
do this thing and when I when I stood up
it was just I had more energy
you test yourself do you have more
energy when you're standing up or when
you're sitting down and so on calls I
would I would not just stand up but I
would walk around I like to have
something going on I often people
comment on some of my videos where I
fidget with my ring so my ring whenever
I'm thinking I like to be
I don't like to be meditative and still
I like to have something going on so I'm
often I'm often fidgeting with my ring
or you might see my ears move up and
down every now and then when I'm
thinking I like walking around just
having something go and it helps me
think and process better
and so that was the starting point was
just okay cordless phone and walk around
then I discovered a stand-up desk I
forget who it was it might have been Tim
Ferriss again way back in the day and
the the test was not a full-on standard
desk because those barely existed but I
took my bookcase
and I cleared off the book and all the
books in the bookcase and I found the
shelf that was the kind of the best
height to put my laptop on and I just
tried standing there and I think this is
a good life hack not just for standing
up or not but just in general if you
want to try something
don't go off and buy the most expensive
thing and wait three weeks for it to be
delivered just go try something right
now
so if you want to try stand up desks
don't go buy a stand-up desk don't do
that that's the worst thing you can do
don't spend a ton of money on a stand-up
desk and then wait three weeks for it to
be delivered to you
just take a bookcase or take some boxes
and put it at the right height and see
how it feels
you want to start a YouTube channel
perfect don't don't go researching and
spend weeks buying the gear and the
lights and the cameras and all that
stuff and it most of that most of the
stuff in these little experiments end up
failing and they now you bought all this
gear that's just sitting in your garage
you know your closet or your mom's
basement
the best thing to do is just start find
a small way to just get started and so
I stood up at my bookcase and the first
day I didn't last very long 20 minutes
40 minutes I it didn't last very long
when you're not used to standing up it
it's really hard it's like oh where I
need to sit down and after that first 20
or 40 minutes I got tired and I had to
sit down because my body wasn't used to
it but while I was standing up like I
really like this this is cool I have
more energy in just answering emails and
whatever else I was doing at the time I
had more energy so I'm gonna try it
again and that 20 minutes became 30
minutes became 40 became two hours
became four hours became six hours to
the point was like I could just stand up
all day long it became weird when people
came over to my office because there
were no chairs to sit down at so when
we're doing a meeting I'm standing up
and so they were standing up because
there were no chairs and it felt awkward
to have one person standing one person
sitting and then they start getting
tired because after 20 minutes of
standing up we got tired so I had to I
had to bring chairs back to my office to
host meetings and
um but that was the process that was the
starting point and it it turned out to
have all sorts of positive health
benefits and I had I had
foot issues I had uh the things that you
put in your in your shoes what's it
called not implants uh customized Souls
whatever I was going to a car like in my
20s I was when a chiropractor almost
every week because my back was was a
mess my knees were were achy and
cracking every time I was walking like
my body seemed to be falling apart in my
20s I'm now 42 in May I'm 42 and my body
is in better condition than I was in my
20s
because a big I think a big factor is
because I'm on a trampoline all day long
instead of sitting all day long with
terrible posture and my body falling
apart now I'm jumping on the trampoline
all day long it's easy on my joints my
body I'm happy I have more energy and as
a result I'm healthier
the move to a trampoline came because I
was I was already standing up for
at least five years
uh maybe more and I saw Tony Robbins do
uh his his seminars and uh
backstage he would always jump before he
goes on stage Tony jumps a couple times
on his rebounder rebounder is just a
mini trampoline not like the giant
trampolines like what you have in your
backyard or rebounder is a mini version
of it that you can keep in your office
or your home or whatever he jumps a
couple times on his rebounder uh sprays
something in his mouth uh does like a
spin and then walks on stage
if you ever see him backstage that's
what he's always doing he jumps on his
trampoline a couple times puts something
in his mouth spins around goes out on
stage ready to go alright so that's
pretty cool I wonder what he's spraying
in his mouth uh and I like the whole
trampoline thing if I'm already standing
up why not get a trampoline and try and
so again what's what's the easiest way
to go off and do it well I I went to my
local Walmart and I bought a rebounder
and brought it home and
had to adjust the height of my desk and
had to raise it beyond what the max
height was and the rebounder I bought
ended up breaking shortly after because
it wasn't designed to be jumped on that
often all day long every day right but
whatever it's fine Lessons Learned right
you figure it out you think do is this
worth doing or not take the idea that
you've got and try because again the
biggest thing that most people are
missing is just momentum you're just not
trying you have this you've got this
idea and we spend our best energy
planning it and ideating and researching
and what's the perfect trampoline and
what's the perfect stand-up desk and you
spend all that energy researching and
then tomorrow you wake up the next week
you come back or the next month or
whatever like nothing has happened on it
still
if all these great intentions but
there's not enough momentum
and so idea to action trust that your
ideas come to you for a reason and go do
something about them
and so go get the stand-up desk by
creating boxes in your office
you know go get the cheapest trampoline
at Walmart and just jump on it and see
how it feels
it's ended up changing my life so
I'm not used to sitting down anymore uh
we actually moved we just sold our place
we bought a new place and I moved uh
into one of the rooms as a temporary
place while we were showing our place
because my office backdrop doesn't is
not very conducive to selling the house
most people are not used to a stand-up
desk a giant stand-up desk and
trampoline and all that and so I took my
office down because when you're selling
a home you wanted to appeal to everybody
and
I sat down for I don't know a couple
weeks while we were selling our place
and all of a sudden the back issues came
back I was cracking my back a lot my
knees started to hurt again my feet
started to hurt again my posture was
terrible again and I realized wow this
is why I stand up
so two lessons in this video the first
is try standing up
yeah you'll probably have more energy
you'll probably feel better it's
probably better for your health people
say sitting is the new smoking right so
try standing up and just give it a shot
and don't stress out if you get tired
after 20 minutes like I did the first
time through it's okay but do you have
more energy while you're working
while you're standing up and if so then
just keep going and just start with the
bookshave for some bookshelves uh or
some boxes whatever just to get started
and the second lesson is is just do
something just momentum imperfect action
the ideas that you have in your head are
great they're genius you need to do
something you need to stop putting the
gas pedal on the energy that's flowing
through you like greatness is flowing
through you and you're actively saying
stop stop stop do something find the
smallest possible way today today like
right now the smallest possible way to
take that awesome idea in your head and
build some momentum towards it
because the only thing you're missing
towards your great life is the momentum
foreign
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome if you want to watch another top
10 rules of Evan Carmichael check out
the video next to me continue to believe
I will see you there well to get rid of
anything you have to be consistent or
anything any skill that you want to
develop you have to be consistent on at
the beginning of a journey it's okay to
experiment and taste and test and try
and do a bunch of things you know I made
my first video